dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly failure in this
series we talked a lot about
photorealistic rendering which is one of
the most exciting areas in computer
graphics research photorealistic
rendering means that we put virtual
objects in a scene assign material
models to them and then run a live
simulation program to create a beautiful
image this image depicts how these
objects would look like in reality this
is particularly useful for the film
industry because we can create highly
realistic scenes and set them up in a
way that we couldn't do in real life
we can have any possible object we can
imagine light sources that we wouldn't
ever be able to by change the time of
the day or even the planet we are on
practically we have an infinite budget
that's amazing however creating such an
image takes a long time often in the
order of hours to days here you can see
me render an image and even if the
footage is sped up significantly you can
see that this is going to take a long
long time fpp means samples per pixel so
this is the number of light rays we
compute for every pixel the more SPP the
cleaner more converged image we get this
technique performs spatio-temporal
filtering this means that we take a
noisy input video and try to eliminate
the noise and try to guess how the final
image would look like and it can create
almost fully converged images from
extremely noisy inputs well as you can
see these videos are created with one
sample per pixel which is as noisy as it
gets these images with the one sample
per pixel can be created extremely
quickly in less than 10 milliseconds per
image and this new denoiser also takes
around 10 milliseconds to reconstruct
the final image from the noisy input and
yes you heard it right this is finally a
real-time result this all happens
through decoupling the direct and
indirect effect of light sources and
denoising them separately in the
meantime the algorithm also tries to
estimate the amount of noise in
different parts of the image to provide
more useful information for the noise in
routine
the fact that the Empire pipeline runs
on the graphics card is a great
testament to the simplicity of this
algorithm whenever you see the term SVG
F you see the results of the new
technique so we have these noisy input
images with one s P P and look at that
wow this is one of those papers that
looks like magic and no neural networks
or learning algorithms have been used in
this work not so long ago I speculated
or more accurately hoped that real-time
photorealistic rendering would be a
possibility during my lifetime in just a
few years later this paper appears we
know that the rate of progress in
computer graphics research is just
staggering but this is this is too much
to handle super excited to see where the
artists will take this and of course
I'll be here to show you the coolest
follow-up works thanks for watching and
for your generous support and I'll see
you next time
Oh
[Music]
you